[Music]
[Music]
aha Yolo I didn't get fired just like
that killing it you're back in Monster
Hunter yeah we got that PC beta that I
mentioned that might have been I was
like Oh two o'clock no I pushed it to
four because I was busy there's a lot of
stuff going on today we'll just hop
right into it
heck yeah this is probably not the best
place for the picture fix it though we
can adjust adjustments live so you can
tell it's it's on the PC cuz I got a
mouse yeah bottom left tube mouse
confirm your mouse keyboard for this
hour hour and a half however you're
probably gonna play controller yeah I
highly recommend planking yeah I think I
think even though I've only played for
like I don't know half an hour unless
two hours into this that's just some of
it was afk it's an hour and a half I
said I played an hour and a half and I
was afk literally 70 of those minutes
let's just make let's just make one
because there are actually people on
yeah well some okay so we have closed
beta we got access via Capcom they gave
us key so not everyone has it the game
comes out next week though so I don't
even know if there's like next week or
two weeks I think it's two weeks oh no
you're right it's two weeks my semblance
of time is terrible
yes this is two weeks it's been ninth
it's ok I don't know if there's gonna be
any type of like beta before that do you
have you heard anything so I didn't know
that they're even doing this kind of
beta access yeah I didn't either I
literally know what the what's going on
here I know that it's on a stream and
you might not be able to get this but
this is so smooth Oh
on that note someone said open video
options oh yeah that's the first thing
we gotta do that sort of got going on
here we're currently Oh 1080p monitor
but we were playing I always playing 4k
outside to get the full option yes yeah
alright that's fine
at least I figured that out we're not
gonna like we're not gonna short change
anyone we're gonna show you all the
stuff this is a bottom right situation
or like where we're at is actually good
I think that's going to cover a part of
the health
top right or bottom right what do you
think bottom right because who cares
about our item s all right so we are
going 1080 because that's just the
monitor that's in here correct we have
no limit on our frame rate which is nice
the options port I think are 30 60 in No
Limit yeah no limit no limit that's
that's where we are just audio doesn't
matter that's not what we're here for we
want these advanced graphical options
take me in give me those advanced
graphical options so even if you set it
to the highest default preset it's not
actually the highest because it doesn't
bring up the anti-aliasing okay hi Scott
copper but we've got everything actually
on highest okay right now so we've got a
resolutely rapid resolution scaling
texture quality ambient occlusion tons
of options actually which I kind of
didn't expect okay again just so you
guys know beta though this is a video
could change day one you never know but
we got dynamic range we got I don't know
what a Z pre passes they have like fov I
didn't see enough of a question I'm just
curious
maybe that's like one of the things that
you're like I went from console the PC
and like destiny to like yeah hope you
know like whole this is the U of U is a
huge huge thing especially its I think
it's a big thing in FPS games pretty
much so just so you guys know we have an
i7 I forget the processor I'm sorry
someone said turn off music and add FPS
indicator I don't know if there's an FBS
indicator thing in here okay we can turn
off vsync okay and we're running at 1070
in this PC just serious if you're
curious yes yeah you're doing it right
let's put it to Joyce yeah 100% first
thing I did did you ever turn it to
muster most her language
no I did in it oh is it like ghek in its
I kind of yeah it's it's a bit like like
Japanese but they've got some weird
flares to it okay monster hunter repo
okay what's up
neo de wolf dragon let's actually do
this people are saying that volume
render really hurts your FPS so that was
the thing I was reading about earlier
too and I didn't
it pop up when I messed around on this a
little bit so that's fine and it didn't
mess up anything at my computer I have
in my desk right Zack wants us to add an
FPS indicator from Steam
oh yeah steam has a thing where we are
that that's your friend playing that's
my friend play it's me killing it oh god
where is it even I don't even this is
like so they updated everything I think
this is actually you can see for me it's
just way too fancy always use months
monster hunter language this is FPS one
in game please and we're trying I mean
if you can tell me how to do it why
don't you keep walking around I'll try
to see how to add I think that's the
steam fps that's honor big big screw or
the big screen motor that's go go to the
in-game section click on the in-game FPS
counter menu default off and select
where you want to be this so out here on
the desktop here do you want me to go
full camera I don't care people can you
send me a thing it's fine everything's
all different now cuz then go on the
in-game FPS counterman so in settings we
got in-game yeah that's I don't even
know okay go to steam settings top left
steam settings yeah okay
there's what go to NSS go to in game F
it's right here okay where do you want
it definitely not bottom right let's put
on the bottom right let's the top left
top right up right in the top boom we're
back in is this going on Steam yeah you
just we're not bad huh what because you
can't tab to it oh oh you know no no
you're in click back to that can you
click into that the the Monster Hunter
that's back there yeah that doesn't work
it's not popping up so you might have to
go out to make it actually accept it oh
I see yeah damn you Chet I'm just
kidding I love you
no that's that's the thing I should have
done before we even get game that's fine
we're good alright okay it's just open
bet I know will not know we have we have
that closed beta life
check the box - did you not check the
box I check the box you're oh I'll
double check the box
oh no they can
your desktop it's a dirty Oh No yeah top
right yeah it's all there
all right boom alright we're getting
back in there there was no box to check
I don't know I think we're getting cold
let's do it it's no book someone also
didn't wanted the nvidia version which
was like alt d' but whatever did you
restart the game we're on it thank you
oh god you guys round two fight we're in
this is a queer never gonna actually
hunt a monster in this whole thing
that's the whole point
yeah oh it's monster hunter fridays back
and it's meat Blackstar what's up black
oh yeah good to see ya is it Ramon I'm
guessing it's Ramon it could be ramen
you want that race don't you black star
yeah sweaty races has to be in a game
retro just use the Nvidia stuff it's
easy LG oh did Joey change or oneis
there you go alright where's hold on let
me help you out on that Corning's he
were to hug layout FPS counter on put it
put it up here boom there it is Danny
we're at 69 70 72 good 7121 these menus
man 44 okay now watch when we dip into a
fight for real all right fine 250 250 a
no problem what is in the top right ah
nothing nothing important let's do it
alright
this is support ultra wide monitors
haven't tried Tim we technically have
one outside I guess we could told you in
video easy boom thank you true we should
listen to I mean you met I am mad at
least you're not again g-man aesthetic
all right what's your mission right now
great job yes so you passed that it's
right after the great generous we've got
to find our second camp oh yeah that's
fine haven't played monster hunter and
you've been waiting to do that on PC
camps are important camps I didn't play
this at all like any monster hunter
before didn't realize how good multiple
camps are lets you fast travel lets you
farm stuff better
more efficient sometimes it lets you get
to a monster that's that's freaking
flying away faster so definitely do that
rise own says thanks for streaming this
by the way of course thank you for
tuning in we appreciate it appreciate
everyone hanging out today what specs
you rockin bro uh I seven I really need
to okay after this dream remind me look
a little exact i7 we can just go back to
the best time I'll try to figure it out
we got a hunt some monsters damnit we
have an i7 1070 in there not a 1070 Ti
is just a 1070 and I believe 32 gigs of
RAM that those are the most important
three things right I don't I can't hard
drive and an SSD stuff doesn't really
matter as much yeah I believe so see you
later
we're okay we're 55 not bad not bad all
things considered oh did you do this - I
farmed everything even though I was like
hey over here
this way I'm like oh there's no owns
over here and there's a mining crop no
no I'm also gonna pick up I think some
of the other camps yeah hundred percent
so and you got oh another pro tip if you
didn't know this bounties bounties are
awesome at least to start definitely
pick them make them up get the easy ones
Ben's got the mining one which is one of
the easier ones as you get farther along
you want to do some of the harder ones
or the ones that you know you're farming
just because it'll give you like Spears
and all that stuff which man is so far
down the road yeah I step I don't even
know 350 hours between this and where I
am and my axe I know I know that's
that's what I'm dreading and scared of
rollin what's up we are GameSpot yes
thank you for tuning in and happy happy
is this open beta or question mark no
unfortunately so it's it's not open and
I haven't heard anything about in open
beta yet this in Psalm was not happy
with the 60fps with a 1070 mmm it's okay
I think I don't know I didn't I've only
played a little bit I haven't done
combat too much mine crashed actually
earlier which I told you about which I
didn't hear that I killed I had a fun
like I killed seven of those small
jogger us and then it just like
no thank you and I was like see you
later but again beta I didn't have any
FPS drops though when I was fighting
them personally but the rig I was
playing on in that and my rig was at my
desk is way beefier it's got ten atti so
but though the interesting thing is you
all were also playing on attending atti
and earlier you're telling me how like
people were having the other weekend
warded problems with the technicality
yeah an article that went up that said
it can't run it at 60fps or something oh
I'm gonna see you later
oh I don't want to fight that I'm
actually surprised it didn't agro you
but that's because it knows I'm cool I'm
just here to hang out I guess so what
graphic settings within a higher highest
so we don't have it set on highest
because highest actually doesn't set
everything to the highest it can be okay
so we have a custom set where everything
is individually cranked up as high as
it'll go gotcha
ah that's stamina yeah sometimes you
just forget you some rations lay on that
shift key show your booty on the camera
I can't do that that breaks Terms of
Service too hot for twitch to cut for
YouTube to probably I will buy this one
says ravu hopefully i said your name
right yeah i think it's cool i think
there's got to be a a group of players
that only play PC games that probably
are waiting to get their hands on this
that didn't play on console do you know
if there's cross play at all I don't
think there is
okay that's unfortunate but it makes
some sense there you know we turn vsync
off I like to be single lot though yeah
so I'm noticing like slight terror
hearing I saw it I thought I am reading
twitch ad doke oh yeah yeah I'm doing
I'm trying my best
we got you yeah look it's the bird
alright so you're using a switch ax
right now which is both one uh one of my
favorite weapons what I made on ps4 I
think that was either your primary or
your secondary
yeah you use long sort of a bit long
sword user and then I needed messing
around more with switch axe and
generations and then I pick it up here
and I'm like yeah this is still really
good I'm gonna keep doing this yeah
switch acts like baby
neurosis what's up Dan says I don't know
if I want to grind back through this on
PC it was fun but yeah I don't
I don't know if I can when you I'm gonna
bring this fun buzzword up for the first
time on this stream and probably not the
last time gonna use it
Capcom desire sense is real yes the
desire sensor no I totally believe in it
because there's a couple of things I was
fighting like elder dragon wise down the
road eat that eat that bug yeah that I
just could not for the life of me get
even though I was breaking the parts
like that you're supposed to you know to
have a higher chance and it
it was a tough it is tough it makes it I
mean unless you're super efficient and
you're like really good at killing
something it gets pretty rough sometimes
you just got to turn off all your wants
just don't plan on anything that's true
that's when you get the gems you get the
tails you get that you know everything
everything that you could ever not want
yet I hope day one driver update fixes
stuff yeah you never know what's gonna
come out like NVIDIA loves doing those
day ones you know or like week ones you
know where they're really trying to like
help you know optimize and whatnot yeah
you need g-sync we do we need cool cool
sync technology I might turn vsync back
on when we're out all right you do that
right so it's the swag acts yeah the
only thing wrong with your comment there
is that you didn't money sign the swag
yeah that's the only thing I would have
asked for but yeah
more glitter the one part of the
microphone is blocking where the the
monster was hens Oh main and you mad
says I have similar specs to the PC that
we're running and he or she gets 80 FPS
and above on 1440p and witcher 3 so i'm
kind of disappointed in the FPS again
guys it's in beta we don't know what
type of graphical improvements or things
like that could happen on day one as we
just or as i just mentioned a lot of the
times you know nvidia will push an
update for game release dates or like
launch days at least i have in the past
so how good are you at this game I think
we're pretty ok average above average I
wouldn't say we're like these speed
hunter
you know like three minute
and kills or anything like that but I'm
like I can I can play like high-ranked I
can play up into doing the like tempered
monsters like oh yeah we can kill
everything it's just how fast is another
story I mean I think I got a near
Gergely if they kill like I don't know
was it I told you what it was one time
and I was like I'm never gonna beat this
time yeah it was like this weird like
everything just like all the stars align
and he like couldn't run away and then
like I kept beating down on him last
year and is like a seven or five to
seven minute newer ganti which is like
pretty good I would say but I'm gonna go
this way
so remember the one that I saw where the
person used the bow when they killed him
in oh yeah they kept 40 seconds he kept
doing the row where waldron it's not
even a wall it was like it's like the
little yeah stick pillar thing that's in
the area that you fight near your ganti
at um oh you you went away from there
you know there was another camp up there
right yeah it's fine okay you know what
else I don't want to farm again from all
the palico gadgets yeah I just go for
the the one for farming and then leave
it at that
the plunder bite yeah that was pretty
good but then I switched off to the to
the drums cuz that [ __ ] is real good
that that sweet music is is really good
we are playing close blade beta for
those asking I should just write closed
beta in there you know what y'all are
onto something and I I don't goof
picking up what you're putting down I
will fix I will fix all the problems
although so the the one weird thing
about the PC controls right now that
I've found is that the the button for
doing your like like for the switch
switch actually switching is on control
and it's really weird because shift is
run yeah and if you're running down a
hill to slide and you have to let go of
shift to hit by the way switch yeah by
the way shift also gets you out of it
sheaths your weapon yeah it's like was
it shifting like x basically I would say
play on a controller unless you really
want to play about it's so it's good I
mean is what you were gonna say I
I'm gonna say it's it's serviceable but
I don't know if I'd recommend it I feel
like I'm in less control of what I'm
doing you shouldn't have told me before
the stream like hey Eric I'm gonna just
chalk up and play on a mouse key where
the whole time because in reality I
think just for the gameplay purpose I
would rather give you a good look if it
gets real bad news to pick up a
controller it'll be fine
get them show you have to fight you need
a controller yeah W a s and D get outta
here
also I'm not a huge maybe okay I
shouldn't say something when I haven't
really gotten used to it but I don't
like the item switching stuff I say that
because you have to hold Q down and then
kind of cycle through it now I wouldn't
be shocked if you could macro that but
something the other word thing is Q also
brings the other radio menu and then
from there you have to press up with
with W to choose this is a real poor
time to be doing that I feel like that's
what I mean it's you be whoa
so the radial menu is control of wasn t
for directions to move more than 40
volume rendering we can it may be the
next mission how about that how about we
do like what you do some will do some
tweaks as we go sure I actually didn't
eat before we came here and now I'm kind
of regretting it so I'm gonna get some
of this going some rations yeah well
look at that stamina boost its God don't
be a noob like me the first time and not
realize that if I just took rations for
free out of the box that I would have a
crap like almost double the stamina look
clear graphics yeah honestly I only plan
on playing on 1080 so honestly the
optimization is not bad at all for
Helios that is yeah what up oh yeah you
know what's cool is he hasn't knocked
you off yet yeah right
ooh this is the best oh it's so much Oh
a controller or something what was that
the fan yeah oh yeah alright it's brain
just leave it then it's okay such a
short cord it's only my lacking only
mile
Lee so if you guys knew where I couldn't
hear but there was like rumbling going
on and both of us were kind of like wait
what is that
and turns out oh that's the worst
feeling yeah right when you're just with
it it's okay though we'll get at this
but then you're not optimal actually no
you're fine now okay for those that
don't know the reason why I said he's
not being optimal we're not we're not
we're friends
is because the interesting thing about
the switch axe if you didn't know about
it from other monster hunter games is we
switched to the switch words of the
blade or the sword version you can see
it kind of glowing blue right now and
now red if you're trying to like really
min/max your dps you don't want to do
that discharge move until it's like red
because you're losing out on DPS
technically but that's mid maximum and
who cares right now about that we're
trying to get these PC controls on them
yeah yeah yeah for sure for sure killed
that chicken yeah we will kill that
chicken it kind of feels at first you
feel real good about yourself about
killing the cool cool aku yeah but then
you really feel just awful about
yourself later when you just feel bad
for it cuz he just dies so fast yeah and
you're like he's just trying to live a
chicken life man he's doing his thing
you don't wants to play some pitching
catch throw a boulder awesome but you
know in the beginning stages you're like
dude I need to kill anything anything
that will give me new armor yeah turned
me into a chicken they dressed me good
all right
yeah and some think about the camera log
not good with Mouse we haven't even
camera I've never liked a Murloc even in
um so this is the way that I like to
camera like I like the the older way of
like using it to just focus on the
monster mmm
so this is yeah climb on its back can
you remap all the buttons we haven't
tried Caronia but I wouldn't be shocked
if you if you could I feel like you
should be able to PC games right yeah
okay Bogar once as you can thank you
nailed it I still hear it yeah you keep
killing the chicken I'm doing it I'm
doing it
yeah it's gonna see it like did I leave
my phone on the side there or something
or someone's calling alright can you
show us the graphic saying we actually
did that earlier and is it limited to 60
FS we're currently running unlimited so
you can you can set it to 30 60 or
uncapped this is good yeah all the jog
are us equals bounty give me this
oh you should oh you're not flash I'm
just gonna I forgot that the it's been
so long since I've used the healing of
first verse you got that that's a thing
that even exists so there's like
different things you can do like let's
say to this guy yeah yeah yeah yeah now
dis charge it combo yeah so this is this
is like maximum deeps is like when it's
blinking red and you you discharge and
ideally you wouldn't be I've got its Q
mere cheese smeared a Yakov says oh man
the higher framerate is amazing yeah the
framerate is what's really bringing it
together for me at least hello my 970 I
5 4690k 16 give a ddr3 ram high still
tenían yeah you'll be fine 1080 I think
yeah I don't know man
I've always just played to what my
system could handle and then you know
whatever that was it's just like alright
well that it is what it is get blinded I
was gonna say see if you have see I feel
really bad like looking at him right now
you need a hunt man it's fine just use a
controller we could we could show see
this like a half an hour but this is the
true piece here this is the whole PC
experience we got to let you guys know
how these these PC controls click we got
to click on everything we got a ways on
everything it's a good time alright so
now we can get out of here
yep red Gans we do know that we can do
key bindings I just didn't want to say
for sure that you could until because we
didn't try it but we have now been
informed so there you go have you tried
to ranged weapons the thing I wanted to
do a swap Allah on the on the stream
actually so might switch over to a bow
okay that's what you did tell me like
you're like well
you know now with the mouse keyboard I
might actually go ranged on PC might do
thing oh my god how is it on PC um
pretty good so far pretty good I think
it's getting acclimated with the muscle
memory for keyboard and mouse that's
really throwing me for a loop it doesn't
feel like the game I played previously
only because I'm not used to yeah
personally I'm still just like the FPS
increases the best thing for me like I'm
I'm really into this you're actually
gonna do
Zil we're playing with 8 on i7 sorry
that I don't know the exact model for
the i7 CPU but that a 1070 and 32 gigs
of ram would turn this back on because
screen tearing is a thing much better
well you're close to what we have she's
ooh but we have more RAM than you I
would say maybe Toby it's hard for me to
like answer the very specific PC build
questions when I only have the version
we have so I haven't stressed tested it
on like different types of graphics
cards and or like processors or RAM so
wait what instant load yeah yeah it was
pretty so fast the loading times are
very good I should time it when we fly
off to a mission cuz that was always
like that although you don't even have
time to actually like eat because the
mission will be ready to go or as soon
as you like pick it usually released in
the like five missions angle stances
what's the FPS like is it relatively
okay or doom and gloom I mean it's been
okay for us again though we might have a
more above-average SPECT PC I would say
yeah relative to like you know the rest
of the world but I mean it depends on
what you're trying to accomplish right
and then also what your current loadout
computer wises let's switch to a bow
really quick
Steve leave I think that you should try
it on mouse a keyboard see how it feels
for you and then try a controller I
think that you should just play
whichever one feels better to you
controller again because my muscle
memory is ingrained in it it made more
sense so I can't say that for sure
keyboard mouse is like awful it's just
that I'm not used to where stuff is and
how stuff works use the boat please he's
on it
I'm already already doing it I might
even try to upgrade it yes at ten six
year yes at ten seventy uh the stable I
think was to the ten sixty hopefully but
that was to Toby's question I think but
again I don't I can't definitively tell
you that but I would feel that if you
have if you're just aiming for 60fps
1080p and your 16 gigs of ram a 10 60
and i7 7700 I would hope that you get
stable 60 but I don't know I need my boy
Michael hi I'm game time game man he
just left I know he's gone for the rest
of the week I'm so sad as Claudius as
mentioned the 1060 is basically the
perfect GPU for this generation to reach
steady 60fps so if he's as knowledgeable
as Michael I am maybe you should be good
its third person I probably use a
controller for this game cool that was
from my John yeah nice lipstick emote I
can't read your name sorry but hello
nice nice
well it runs 60fps 1080i a GTX 970 16
gig of ram 6600 k processor that's hard
to say
I don't know about 970 that that might
be asking for a bit to be 1080 60 but
you never know again don't know alright
so I'm using we're using a 1070 so we're
gonna hit go on this this Pooky Pooky oh
oh that's easy-peasy actually he's
pretty annoying the first time you have
antidotes I'll find it or if I just want
to like see how fast this load seems
already it's already ready to go right
no but like from here to the actual
estera though how long does that take
oh I'll count in my head do I have
anything inside of here yeah I do
yeah you have nine antidotes already so
you should be good I just no don't take
hold on this this is where everything
gets weird
just like I pick here first and then I
pick here that's the store so I should
just maybe want to take ya want to take
can I just hit hold on what's the button
for just filling it up store on at the
bottom there's a lot of button this it's
it's so weird I'm just going to do this
take confirm do it do it do I
I'm clicking you have to confirm on the
actual thing the green okay so that's
how that works
is this 1080 60 well we're playing 1080p
cuz of the monitor and our frame rate is
technically on uncapped or unlimited
right yeah the setting that we're at
right now bc herbes that's kind of how
it goes sometimes I mean it doesn't it
doesn't reach everyone that we have
subscribed but if you subscribe it'll
help you get informed as to when we go
live it's true we go live everyday our
normal time for guess what daily is 11
where we do the biggest gaming news in
about 15 minutes or less and then we're
live again at 11:30 with GameSpot live
where we generally play you know the
newest games um you know if we have
preview for games games that have like
weekly challenges like fortnight we used
to do monster hunter all the time we're
gonna have to start having a community
kind of driven show where Ben and John
Luke are gonna try to play games with
y'all on Friday so come back for that
I'm sure Monster Hunter will be one of
those games for you know to get to what
else do we do fortnight challenges stuff
like that something I was going hit it
up sorry I'm trying to get all the
questions so I just kind of scrolled up
and he's we're gonna use the bow right
now so you guys can know and so V in
this game looks like double speed you
know what it could feel or look that way
backlash because I remember from
personally when I went from destiny to
console to playing on PC it felt faster
on PC for whatever reason so yeah can
you use FPS counter like IGN did we
totally our top right it's in green
it's the Nvidia one yes it would look
good using yep don't worry we got the
bow at GameSpot says he has poor control
arm PC show ps4 buttons or Xbox buttons
dad I don't know if it shows Xbox
buttons okay I haven't tried a ps4
controller though how do I actually aim
this
is it is it oh you have to hold V yeah
oh this is this isn't how you're
supposed to lose recap bad but this is
this is the default and this is what
they think is good okay fine I'm gonna
make it work all right you do you
actually might pick up the controller
halfway through it oh that's come on
come on don't do that you don't need to
do that
how's the low times on PC pretty quick
yellow Sanchez good to see you
how can again the beta currently there
is no beta for the public we're on
closed beta that we were lucky enough to
get from Capcom so that is how we're
playing so many good questions here
trying to get through all of it does
vsync make the game feel less responsive
it doesn't feel like it okay at least in
what I've done since I changed it Errol
M yes I agree palak O's are great rusty
we're using a 1070 what a Spartan asked
what are your guys's favorite weapon
mine is switch axe and then I like
spamming dual blades I guess maybe I
might go dual blades this time cuz I I
think I wanted to on console but I got
so used to switch axe that I just was
swag axe life I guess
I don't know some people say that uh the
dual blades are kind of newbie and
they're like really easy to use don't
let that stop stop you from doing what
you want to do I wouldn't leave this
game right here bad forget about it I
okay so now I used this to do my my
items before we just don't have a 1 144
Hertz monitor in here rusty oh now it's
that's fun
what so you can your hold I wonder if it
works no because you have to you have to
hold down queue and then you do left and
right Mouse to change what's on your
actual item bar and then you scroll up
and down to change your om with types
okay got you
cuz before I could scroll and it would
change what I was using with my past oh
you're talking about just specifically
because we have power coatings okay guys
so I think they changed that I kind of
liked where I could scroll to go through
all my actual stuff I mean you can also
you can also later on but you can really
you can upgrade your or not upgrade you
can change your radial wheel to that's a
pretty big one as well you guys use an
SSD I don't know where been installed
this to so it might not be on the SSD
but that would obviously Drive name yes
I probably ha d I believe was their only
sandy it was what it was on D and I
didn't take anything else goes my I
don't think I don't think that's that
says D so there you go
yeah will you do a stream on once 100x
final fan so you'll see I'm gearing up
for that I stopped playing storm blood
right after I finished the storyline
back when it first came out so I'm gonna
need to grind out some gear before I'm
able to do it but I'd be down there you
go there's a gameplay better on the
mouse and keyboard controller as dark P
that's hard to say I think that for me
and Ben were both used to controller so
we're gonna this is Oh thing
instinctively say it's are you saying
it's it's harder because of the v4 so oh
my goodness for him to scope in you got
use be the button beep but that's just
default and then there has to be a
better way to go through all of the
stuff in my inventory to that I just
don't know yet yeah like I said it's
muscle memory right so right now he's
having to hold queue or well he could
radio dial it to I don't know where it
is on the top left is a heel looks like
if that's what you're trying to do and I
don't even have anything out there now
and then my d-pad on my keyboard to
change what type of shortcut I'm doing
anarchy there's no way for the public
again in the beta right now and if there
are is information going forward about
how to get into a public beta assuming
there is one you'll find out at Gamescom
I started to repeat what are the
settings that we are on Ben has the
highest basically put highest on each of
the settings that he could manually
which isn't actually somehow the highest
great gosh yeah they they don't want you
actually turn everything up it's like a
it's like a safe high for the preset so
they actually turn every single option
up you have to do it manually
these buttons are a thing yes this is
have native support for the ps4
controller doesn't sound like it but I
haven't tested it did you uh it might
because it's on Steam okay but you said
that you would see the Xbox buttons
right
oh he just said earlier yeah you can see
the Xbox buttons when you've got the
controller in even with the ps4
controller I haven't done a PS work okay
good
how much better do the camera controls
feel on keyboard mouse I don't know
it feels like it's designed to be done
with an analog stick because there's
like a little bit of like delay also how
do I do that is it both hold on so if I
oh my goodness are you trying to capture
something I'm trying to I'm trying I'm
trying to exist oh wow it's so zit it's
not both because that's how you do that
is it these ones so I'm trying to show
the control settings really quick zero
terrible that it's are so okay so that's
how you put the power coating in and
then that's how I do the okay yeah that
moves key everything I heard is charged
yes it's it's about the the Dragon
piercer for sure what we want what were
you looking for
control saying yeah it's probably not
gonna go anywhere we're probably fine
controls and watch we fail the mission
because that's fine
Oh keyboards I think there you go okay
so you can change everything which is
good oh and there's melee and ranged
weapons as well as you get into the
nitty-gritty cool cool
we got separate stuff for everything so
do you want to chant oh no you probably
don't to mess with it right now I don't
reticle V uh you know I'm just gonna go
with it cuz I'm starting to kind of
understand where the buttons are yeah
and there's I don't want to sit here in
rebind oh right in front of you yes CJ
Francis come to me at Monster Hunter PC
soon it'll be yours CJ good to see you
too by the way
Pierce that can you show us controller
yeah we'll do that like the last half an
hour I guess a stream I'll uh let then
actually have some real fun I thought
I'd like really test at least try like
like hey this is all the PC stuff yeah
what's up your ass
hello thanks for stopping by oh my gosh
oh I don't know about that unreal
internee but I hope the best for you he
wants to play with the FX 6200 and gtx
760 you're welcome to try she's you I
don't know if you'll like definitively
based off your specs get high for sure
the game audio super low all right here
you go get you some puke a puking noises
Oh buster no gtx 750ti can play I mean
sure I don't know at like what graphical
setting you'll be able to play but I'm
sure it'll be very much playable on
a1050 assuming the rest of yep geez
but there's difference to the ps4
version while button layouts with
keyboard mouse is different what else is
different so far
not today loading is PI faster on PC any
limited editions would be available
actually I haven't looked to see if they
had I don't like any collectors or
anything I don't know if we do either I
know that there's the the base Edition
and the digital deluxe it comes with
like the samurai transmog set yeah are
right now a zero terrible mentioned I
believe are the drivers installed on
isn't even an SSD if I recall correctly
Joseph if asks I've heard the distance
volume setting gets rid of the watch
watched out filter have you have could
you test this we can check it out down
box around 1070 just normal 1070 not Ti
and he flies away could you please
connect a controller and show us
gameplay yeah we totally can I probably
need to get you a longer cord though huh
oh there's one right there
easy peasy everything's good we'll do
that the last I don't know
you can set numbers to the items it was
on the Capcom's official webpage oh
that's really good it's like the old Wow
it's just like have you tried the horn
yet no no no yeah I'm also not very good
at horn yeah I mean to really have good
use of the horn I first was a double
Joe's horn that was opposed to be like
Oh P something like that I think God
deviljho was a golden devil Joe was
probably the hardest thing I've fought
ever in this game
it took me half an hour to kill him I
believe I felt bad about myself but I
did kill him so that Lisa is that you
can map poaches the numbers right yeah
it sounds like a ninja guard we just
haven't tried yet
Kenny hockey I knows only use 8 items at
all time I mean you can hockey to the
radio and people are mentioning that you
can hockey them to numbers to obviously
Hawking to eight would be pretty far for
your finger reach though in my opinion
but I mean if you have long dexterous
fingers maybe it's all good it's perfect
for my MMO Mouse oh yeah your razor like
a Naga or something you know
don't even have that anymore maybe video
they got the whole room hey tell Capcom
to have ps4 to PC save Chester's I wish
ninja garden you know how fast I would
then easily convert it over yeah right
but I doubt that very much
our team hey again just let me throw
that throw this out there for the people
asking me about or asking us about specs
and like if it'll run on high or
whatever since we haven't played it on
it I for both of us we've only played it
on a 1080 TI and a 1070 so anything
below that I wouldn't be able to tell
you if you'll for sure get 60fps at 1080
you know attic with lower than what I've
mentioned I can't tell you that for
certain
so yeah right in the face I shouldn't
worry yeah we're in the kisser so please
stop asking me I guess
Jeremy Mills 1070 i7 32 gigs of ram I
don't know exactly which I said might be
the 7700 but I'm not 100% sure so yeah
where's the so you can do like a dash
into a melee attack and I don't I don't
know enough about Bo to help you man I
would be doing exactly what you're doing
feathering I know power coding does a
lot of damage if you want to burn your
power coding any support for 20 y21 by 9
ultra wide I haven't tried that either
we do have an ultra wide in the office
that I guess we could probably try
testing it at some point I'm a 960 I
have hopes yeah I mean like I said that
was no juice left I think it just
depends on what your I don't know like
really trying to aim for like it's
probably gonna be playable on 960 it's
just like what is it gonna look like I
don't know yeah after a - you can melee
says Tessa
tests ryousuke sorry does this support
more support multi-monitor not sure
about that either sorry
Nashawn Iser says I got rid of my I sold
my ultra ride because I got sick of
asking that question every time a new
name came to hell that's fair
rusty Shackelford says I will only wish
there was metric showing how much of RAM
was being utilized for this that sounds
like some digital foundry next stare
reading YouTube live comments by the way
guys I'm reading both actually so if you
read if you send via twitch to I'm
seeing that as well and thanks to those
watching on GameSpot I think it's are
after a - is what society says look at
the top right it's our GameSpot there it
is we got it everyone yeah yeah that's
that's the stuff that I like that's the
Slamma jamma
oh we need those earplugs all right see
that's when the drums kick in got that
earplugs Bluff and you're like oh yeah
just yell all you want it don't matter
I recommended his three gigabyte beer am
says yellow Santa's strays are 1070
triangle attack what switches weapons
and other games should do it I guess
can i play this on a 1050 TI I'm sure
you can play on it I just don't know how
good it'll be I'll play on mine tonight
true there are no graphical improvements
over console I don't know about that I'd
say that the textures are definitely
higher like much higher or a lot of
details I had never noticed until I
played it earlier today yeah as rusty
mentioned yeah I'm pretty sure you can
just lower your like graphical settings
that you know or something but it does
it doesn't it correct me if I'm wrong
then does it it kind of picks what's
best for you right based off your
machine well I just want to know changed
it I didn't even look okay
whoa nailed it right off the top
everything fade away get out of here oh
[ __ ]
where the boys over here oh you're gonna
do the running thing oh my gosh he's
gonna do the right
mr. yoke says the frame rate or the
frame time seem to be free solid hardly
any frame draws which means pretty
smooth gameplay cool yeah I haven't
noticed anything
it feels really smooth even if it looks
like it's dipping like a couple of
frames up at the top yeah still feels
really good I don't have any of my
equipment I know I know what that it's
just like I'm thinking about all the
stuff I would be using if I could but I
know you can't you know that's fine I'll
take it
I haven't tested it out yet Joseph the
option you had mentioned to us earlier
but we can check that out on the next
mission or something like that
can you try seeing if ps4 controller
will work I had to walk out of the room
to grab one we're definitely gonna do an
Xbox controller though I can see if I
can grab ps4 controller if that's
something you guys plan a Nintendo
switch pro controller oh that PI because
that's supported on Steam yeah that's
true do I run through the gamut and
bring everything in I don't know if we
need to get that that deep
[Music]
good that was good broke apart broke
apart oh you use the power cards oh yeah
those would be good try not to get too
crazy with it
why not it's not like you're gonna use
the bow anytime soon I can always just
buy stuff later on to set doesn't matter
I need to keep reminding myself talk
press v to like get out of bring a fight
stick to alright oh heck yeah that's
what we're talking about for all those
asking about the rig what I'll try to do
is I'll put it in the description going
forward just so people know ash Rimmer
played earlier in his fps are 110 to 140
in all high settings you must have a
pretty good rig rig dodo dodo
ps2 junky let's see there we go
yes Spartan yes we could we did know
that thanks for the tip that we can run
off walls and do the like kind of like
jumping over shoot animation which is
pretty cool Oh get the Rocklin oh my god
the buttons come on stay there no I
can't believe this no we got it anyway
nails got his tail his fat tail that's
what he gets been alright for the body
another one yep very good
just try them all try a couple
[Music]
right in the face ooh he didn't like it
you didn't like it
I think PS too drunk you would say it's
just to answer the PS controller
question it does work we can always try
it yeah
Joseph says Xbox controller does work
yeah we know where that one works for
sure I guess I could bring in other
controllers to test if that's instead of
the Xbox controller come back uh Mac
walk
I don't believe well we're not sure
actually we'll have to see if the ps4
controller actually shows the PS button
prompts or not or if it just shows Xbox
I only will start going down here before
I could jump on them oh hello
see you later nope
distant sama I don't remember which
exact i7 is might guess was 7700 K but
we could also look at that after the
fact after we finish up with the stream
we can have been and go into settings it
could be an 8700 I just can't remember
I've built a couple pcs for the office
and starting to forget what's got it
dude write on it no that's not what I
wanted though what did you want Dragon
piercer yeah it's fine that move does a
lot of damage doesn't it it's not not as
much as that are not as much as the
dragon piercer good
oh yeah it's like trips I guess
oh when can we expect for kpc footage on
your YouTube that's a good question
great Powerful oz I guess we could
technically get some tomorrow maybe
because oh here we go that's that's what
you hear yeah don't forget to uh to you
know loot that tail later yeah I've done
that so many times where I'm like oh
yeah finally no the fire can rocks now
oh no engine ass get out of here
oh he's blinded by the spore cloud stuff
in them or confused God is so good this
is real good Angelo he's spreading his
wings
yeah bytom get him help us yeah you two
fight drop those red rocks on a really
pissing off oh yeah we're not
oh god that's not what I wanted to shoot
at all huh
what if it's me I'm here oh boy alright
time to retreat let's not be here
anymore let's let's not
here have some poison oak you left click
got it nailed it oh geez
no problem oh man he is not happy look I
shot him in the head
casaya sushi says ps4 controller is
supported by steam so it should work
yeah the question would be does it have
the ps4 button prompts or not that would
be interesting one I will literally go
grab anything set in a second
courage is likes to co-op more in this
game where someone else said they're
great single-player yeah
I think if you played either way I
soloed a lot of it I don't know I could
see the fun of multiplayer but then and
also the whole death thing gets kind of
annoying good natural performance looks
great in any case yeah it looks good
looks smooth
how's the performance it's good Andre
for the most part so far for us extra
one in 1080p right now you aim with a
mouse I yeah but you have to hold B to
get that social circle thing you have to
do V to actually aim aim and then from
there you press
like our and then right-click at the
same time to do a dragon piercer and
look at the top right you'll see all the
but yeah you can you can see what we got
a go with but other than that like some
of the stuff like dodging and all that
makes sense give him that sick flash
fire Firebug now you can't see you're
dizzy come on Buster go get in there
now's the time what is GUI been doing
the tail go back and get the tail I
don't know I don't know better we have
enough time I think we can make it
PC saying sorry octo oh I probably
should have put that thing on does it
look better with a volumetric on or off
we're okay right yeah we got beta
disconnections it's fine okay stream
earlier I thought the volumetric stuff
looked weird
tycoon ajv how are the controls using
only keyboard I think they're just it's
more about getting used to it
yeah the unfamiliarity it's right now
I'm definitely stumbling and tripping
trying to like do like important things
that you need to do for this weapon but
I feel like with time you'll get it you
can also customize all the buttons to do
whatever you want to oh maybe I can't
get it Daniel asked this thanks both -
both peeps hosting for answering
questions and viewers in chat for
responding gamers Rock yep it's a it's
been a fun time so far thank you guys
all for tuning in chatting with us if
those errors didn't pop up we want you
just thinking about that that feels bad
oh it feels bad it's fine it's will get
more tales later on what if you need a
[Music]
tailor to make something yeah exactly so
there's no ultra wide support I can't
confirm or deny that but if that's the
case then there you go how big is the
game in terms of gigabytes in other
words our beta was about six 16.9 yeah
like seven a little under 17 and I don't
know if that's like the whole full
version and if that's the same so that's
gonna be the size for sure
michael says with keyboard what is the
the combo for like square and circle at
the same time so square and circle is
our and right now
if that gives you an idea of where that
is is there rain on console I think so I
think so too yeah
all right let me go grab some
controllers yeah yeah that thing huh
I'm down for how long do you guys have
early access I mean we have it till game
comes out and for us at least and we're
allowed to stream like three hours yeah
we've got three hours of footage we can
do stuff with we can technically do
today and possibly another one but the
games coming out soon August 9th that
rora anja trolled you yeah we got rekt
man feels bad I'm gonna I'm gonna put
the bow away for now we we ventured that
I figure that's fine can you guys give
me any tips to pull off the circle plus
l2 countermove I don't even know black
star I can't help you with that probably
you got a ps4 controller yeah I'm on it
grab them controllers all right once I
can do that thing I kill my mic I really
want to learn how to use the I want to
learn how to use this but I can't do it
it's too I'm down with whatever I'm not
I'm not particular so if we're able to
play this on a on a switch pro
controller that's gonna be real wild see
I want to start looking at the chat now
because Tay was handling it pretty much
the whole time is the FPS locked at
60fps no there's actually an option to
lock it to 30 60 or just to set it free
to do whatever it wants to do which is
pretty pretty rad some head up to the
workshop know if it will support ultra
wide no clue I haven't gotten a chance
to start it up on an ultra wide monitor
yet and I haven't got a chance to read
anything about it
but here's hoping because ultra wide
monitors are a thing that exists do they
have pre download from Austin hunter
world I hope so
it's still two weeks out so use the
charge but I wish I could use the charge
blade but that's that's gonna be a worse
show than the bow I don't know if you
guys want to see that yes see steam has
a switch pro controller support which is
why we're gonna grab one to see if it
works just to kind of test all the
options that we
have available how does the PC version
stack in terms of graphics against the
console it's much much more pretty and
the fact that it can run at 60 or more
frames a second like just that alone is
enough for me but also the load times
are a fraction of what the RN console
and also the textures are a bit higher -
it's like the the thing that stuck out
to me in terms of like noticing
something that wasn't there before is
the handler actually has like a crest on
the back of her thing and I didn't
notice that until now due putting that
pro controller like let's just go with
the most ridiculous one first does the
mouse control feel like it has negative
mouse acceleration what if it was meant
to attract a kind of actually that's
that's a bit what it like what it is Rob
says he doesn't think this is gonna go
well
we got as in the the pro controller I
don't think it would either but it's
worth trying I heard it I heard it sense
a thing I just put on my headphones I
don't know I says how's every point it's
so much better yep I don't think that no
or is it because we're in the game no
that shouldn't matter our hold on let me
plug in your ps4 controller yeah no go
on the switch pro controller apparently
unless there's something else that we
need to do with it but hey we plugged it
in and we tried so that's pretty good so
really well optimized then if from the
two different computers I've gotten a
chance to play it on it runs fairly well
both machines are really beefy though
yeah so they're fairly beefy alright so
this is that we played it on or seen it
this is rope supposedly only works on
bluetooth oh really
there you go she'd be able to configure
steam with the switch pro controller
yeah we might have to get back to that
well we'll get back how's that one so
this this works all right we got ps4
controller this is in prove to them that
you're on a ps4
so the
this is plugged in but it doesn't look
like it's changed the button layouts so
it's still so still Xbox stuff we got
why to see the player list or be to go
back okay so defaults to okay so you go
low setting for fun do you guys really
want to see that like a potato mode like
a mini oh no you know what don't do it
don't do like we might do a potato mode
that's why we don't want to ruin it but
then lo doesn't really do anything it's
the potato fire it's the magic that joy
the potato filter yeah I think we might
have to restart the game if we do that
which might slow things down 10:17 an i7
Ezreal Lucian c-can you try turning off
volumetric now yeah once you try turning
that off oh look you're using a
controller it feels a lot better
everything is like the way it should be
it's real wild is it something I can do
here can I do it later so we're looking
at volumetric magic
yeah where'd that be Joseph there Joseph
dynamic range resolution scary volume
rendering quality we'll have to wait a
second for Chad to catch up probably
enable ds4 controller support in the
controller setting check it out that
enforcer things nope yeah take me back
go back
that's the change like I said it would
be switch those - settings I don't know
if there's any one of the unless it's
called volume rendering quality
alright so volume rendering quality is
that that might have been it then you
have volume rendering quality is that
what it is just change it let me
double-check I'm gonna put it down - oh
you can just switch it to off so you can
kind of see actually in the background
it puts like a kind of bluish filter on
some of the stuff back there that's what
I said yeah it's whack turn it off let's
let's turn off we'll go with it
thanks sue team duty and never upon a
time and I miss someone - a hot Sammy I
think yeah I feel like the colors more
out like there's there's more there's
more green that's play with that off
forever let's thank you taking to the
controller's answering questions yeah we
might have to set up the the pro
controller Pro contributor work do you
just plug in the ps4 controller yes just
plug literally just plugged in our yeah
so Joseph says yeah it's a volume
rendering quality that people said
turning off removes the washed out
filter yeah it looks looks like yeah I'm
into it what's up what the fees says
code a firewall I didn't say that the
other word that he want off looks better
than on yeah does this game support HDR
that I don't know I don't even know if I
saw him in the option does that oh are
you showing them the food because people
hope you want to see the food stuff yeah
they want to see what that food looks
like that's 60 FPS cat food preparation
yeah give me that I don't know what you
have right now cuz you're basic yes boy
I wish that like we had the ability to
come everything ish delicious alright
and then you got kebabs it's a good time
someone's vsync off so we had vsync off
before but yo ma it's a 1070 i7 32 gigs
of ram I will look up what the i7 is
after this
allegedly turning volume rendering
quality to its lowest setting yields the
most FPS or turning it off so we've got
we turn it off because yeah we'll see Lu
filter yes
rep Jan says looks better without the
filter yep probably improves performance
too turning it off yeah we'll find out
of all you mix the game with blue yep
I'm hungry now I know me too dude same I
think I forgot to eat lunch Sam Sammy
and deputy oh really good yeah and you
run free or do whatever you want to do
or do you have to stay to a story so you
kind of have to stick to certain story
beats until it kind of comes up right
after like two missions you can go out
into any area you've already explored
and just run around in fight monsters
with no like limit on anything so it's
it can be open but it's only open as
much as this map Sergeant booty slap
says you have all you metrics can bring
down FPS okay now that's off so that's
good it looks so much better like you
can actually see stuff off from the
distance yeah or did you turn it on
maybe that was what dam says I need some
effin steak now meets a man dude big say
so really 15 days mister yolk it feels
like it's sooner than that c9 is one two
three four oh no it is like 50 names man
my bad our character server-side or will
this be nothing but save editing so this
is really great because I don't know if
it you can do like save editing stuff
which which would be interesting to find
out but I do know that it does cloud
save yes so I was able to move my
character that I made out at my desk
into here without having to do anything
that's good
ninja Garcia speed run to high-ranked
yeah that's not we're on our way this
this is my favorite part of the speedrun
the unskipable cart mission like dude
remember how I told you at the beginning
of this stream I said that I crash after
the first not even the great Jagger
estimation I was on that just like the
basic Jagger house mission it crashed on
me and I had to do the whole touring the
the town all over again
yeah and that's and you just didn't
wanted to it
this is lunch second lunch this just
makes so much sense what I'm sure that I
could play with a keyboard and mouse if
I got a chance to actually mess with
keybindings yeah I think that it'll be
easier for those folks that have never
played on the controller to get used to
the PC 14 potentially but I will say I
enjoyed my experience with a controller
a lot of this stuff just as I mentioned
made a lot of things try 4k resolution
can't unfortunately because one we don't
have a monitor for it and two you
wouldn't get that across the stream
anyways so but I I feel like giving a 4k
clip would probably be a good thing to
do like just 4k Tessa yeah sushi says
other streamer earlier crash too near
the three hours of uptime well hopefully
depending on where he was at it's saved
because the weird thing is I was always
under the impression at least with on
console on ps4 every time he kind of
loaded into like another area it was
like auto saving your last yeah like it
would save like oh you left town then it
saves in town right and then like you
you know whatever but it didn't do that
for me at least so I don't know how that
exactly works most hated monster in this
game bagel goose really yeah I've never
had a problem with a bagel he's the
giant welcome to high-ranked get one
shot guy he's fine Basil's bagel goose
bagel juice is my friend I feel like I'm
devil devil hoe later on not even devil
joke devil hoe was I did not like that
boy he he really just just was a hot
[ __ ] oh the gold version is just a hold
another thing that I don't want to talk
about normal Joe's actually not that bad
it's golden deviljho that really just
like nope
killed him once and there was like never
again never again so it didn't make too
much of a difference for the FPS but
I'll turn off vsync for you guys again
just to do it
I mean that's the screen tearing is just
a thing oh look we're at 90 though we
did it we're up in those those high
numbers now yeah sergeant booty slap
says honestly feels more fluid on
controller it does yeah again I mean who
knows our bows and bogans easier that's
sweet word aiming and shooting is good
but doing the extra abilities was a heck
of a task fart craft unfortunately it
seems like it's keeping the Xbox layout
it I'm wondering if that's a thing like
it has to like exit out and like the end
if you want to go in and out real quick
although is juicy frames cold there here
we found them you can play mouse
keyboard Mong
yeah but why go back I want to be able
to plug in a PSP and after like claw the
the thing just to do anything blazin
monkey says our summer events available
on the PC version from the board under
events I don't think so because like you
have we haven't even gone through most
of like the missions for a lot of stuff
to unlock yet yeah I don't also this is
still like two weeks out from the game
being out so I don't think they have
anything going yes also too good I'm not
really sure why that weird volume
quality thing made the ruins the frames
I don't know enough about that it looks
like it looks so much better without it
on I know luann dad says Monster Hunters
intended for a controller always has
yeah yeah I mean hopefully if you own a
PC and you're thinking about running it
on a PC that you know you just go it's
cool that you can try an troller like
offline ass dark PA I think right now
disconnect yeah I've played offline
multiple times on a console too just
because of our corporate Internet so
yeah thanks for the vsync off says no
Jews left I got you
Wayne D just got here what specs are we
playing on i7 forget exactly which model
1070 32 good clear
normal 1070
50 - somebody said that it did not
support widescreen but I'm not 100% sure
because I haven't tested a linear M yo
how are the frame rates noticed any
jittering or studying present in the
game I didn't really notice any but I
have played as much as Ben but weird
only like a couple hours in some hard to
say but I mean it seemed fine like when
the engine ass showed up while you're
fighting the pukka pukka was fine I
didn't see anything like definitely
nothing glaring yes for sure where it
was like and between the two of us it
only crashed on you ones yep so far in
our limited time plan but again its beta
so definitely par for the course
I love how when you find a footprint you
like pickups and and sniffing you're
like yeah have you ever found that like
rare bird that like rides on that those
guys sometimes it's like a white bird
oh no they show up every now it's like a
thing that you can captured yeah but you
got to be real sneaky where it flies
away it's like a rare pet that you can
own or whatever so it might look like
there's more vegetation Christian
because the the draw distance for all of
it's much much higher it might be more
than that what's that that's that guy
mr. Barratt hmm mud tracks yes
seems like a barrel man I remember
looking for Investigations to get high
ranked so I just got here and maybe it's
already been asked hey man don't worry
about it it's all good
is this a closed beta for pressed
streamers only I think right it seems
like that yeah because I actually didn't
even expect a beta at all until
literally last night we're like oh
there's a beta I guess there's a quick
let me hit the PC brown button so Peter
Brown help we got to take this to the
stream we've got to take it to the
people yeah the people need it they need
to know how Monster Hunters gonna shape
up on piece loading times are definitely
better Philip I cannot confirm or deny
right now if it's on the SSD if it is
it's going pretty fast if it isn't even
on the SSD it can go faster
it's true imagine instant load times you
didn't upgrade your longsword it has
yellow sharpness yeah we haven't farmed
enough and materials to like probably
have an upper grade Jagger is a long
story that doesn't take I should have
should've got that upgrade I didn't even
think about it we're just too excited to
go know what weapon you wanna mean yet
right yeah although some people I know
won't have multiple weapons I'd never do
that
I'm definitely gonna play with a
longsword and switch axis like that's a
given AK xiri on says loading times on
pc make me extremely happy it's not
gonna say the word you said good it's
good substitution
they almost try to get me on the no
man's sky stream well yeah I saw their
things and I wasn't Hannah
well they pull up the was it the the
ninja thing cuz I saw the whole chapel
garbage that I had to really smooth out
that day I'm glad chats being good today
yeah you guys are good I like you but
everything on low I missed that when
everything on low could also make it go
really fast yeah but why would you want
to play on one I'm curious how low it is
I wonder how I want to see how low low
like stacks up to the console version or
like where what what would the console
version be at PC sue she says and I
don't know if this we need to try it
that there's a way for you did not
display Homans yeah there is its it's
the options there's it's been in there
in the console version Billy never knew
what a scrub Oh
so I could have not been using that
student I patched the whole time that's
a fashion hunters - how dare you also
that's the peak of fashion I only use
the eye patch cuz it's got so much GD
Crito is a crit it's exposure yeah w e
yeah it has weakness exposed to and that
is just like wean it's exposed I said
that weakness good anyways just talking
about elbows of course
typical a long sword main sword me swag
axe means over
here manse wagons I try to play all the
weapons I just have a long sword right
now hey Brian keep we are on PC as the
title Oh Wayne D 1070 normal we good
mate yeah gotta get someone to play this
on a potato oh don't you fret well it
gets a potato action going you know
what's gonna happen yeah how much longer
are you streaming as rainbow carnage uh
what are we started for probably like
will probably kill is bear off then
check some of these settings that people
want us to check and call the stream
probably I think Ben's still got to
record something with Joey after this
and you know it'll save us another like
90 minutes if we want to you know get it
to get another PC stream this is a
romantic now going before launch you
know I'll tell you could you possibly
make it well you'll find out in a couple
of weeks probably nice shake it well
played W pwp hunting-horn for the win
yeah respected the people that use the
hunting-horn I've never been good at it
although I just know for sure that the
devil Joe hunting-horn was supposed to
be pretty godlike that's all I know
why 30fps recommended spec on Steam then
I would imagine that like Steam is
probably trying to like give you like
more of like a base like most people
SPECT species maybe I don't know
ooh-whee tshane papa
dude they look so weird now yeah you
know what mine aren't like that yet
really but maybe because I didn't Steam
update no no that also might be the big
dude weakness exploit is legit you gotta
have it we exposed to expose three you
need three to max out okay if you get a
gem if you don't we nice expose Jen
that's keep saying it I'm trying to say
weakness to keep saying weena I'm saying
weakness oh you're hearing weenus
there's two different there
anyway potato mow please oh no it's
coming it's weakness six foot exploit
okay sorry week weenus exploit I said on
purpose I said at that time the press
circle plus r2 right after any attack
you to you to perform a counter-attack
yeah the counter is really good actually
you can get really good with a longsword
I mean it's a pretty good weapon to
start off with but you can get really
really really optimized with every
weapon to be honest but it doesn't
matter to if you you play that way or
not you don't have to do that this is a
fun move okay kind of like the dual
blades cuz you do that move where you
spin all the way along the back yeah try
to can't wait till there's a mod to show
damage and health bars I know I rather I
used to I used to complain about that
actually but then now it's I I get it
you know you didn't understand you
become one with the monster exactly and
you understand what these monsters are
feeling weekend they're limping they're
missing a tail like either brain even
you can't even whip me with that tail
anymore come at me bro
yeah come at me or or come at me sis in
in array thien's I miss the perspective
there's a lot of good stuff in this
level mining outcrops everywhere yeah
radiance said is not bad I never got
into the bear offset cuz um I think it
was more for like hammer if I'm not
mistaken
oh yeah you can have a run into the
thing and you'll stumble to you then if
you have the calicoes come out it helps
you goes up there or whatever they are
yeah there you go what a dummy oh you
dropped some material to you yeah it's
okay cuz we do spirit Blaine it just
goes through it
TM HD I'm not sure what the pre-order
bonuses are to be honest Wayne D we have
the volume lighting volumetric lighting
off so that is yeah that doesn't shock
me that that took 20 FPS cuz we're we're
running at a steady like 90 Plus now
fighting this monster we also have vsync
off so yeah that was a good shout Thank
You Joseph if I think he's the first one
to bring it up and they can do the rest
of chat for telling us about that that's
a big one tofu Maggie yeah almost like
magnet we are on a 1070 i7 that I need
to confirm for you guys which I said it
is and 32 gigs of ram normal 10 seconds
the one thing I was trying to avoid a
lot for new monsters and maps yeah I
don't know man I can't wait for the mods
that turn like bear off into the grimace
because you know someone's gonna do it
or like it doesn't matter if he sharpens
his web or not because we only have
yellow sharp this is the deal we're on
day 1 longsword so sorry
wicked decision we didn't have a monster
part we're here hunting we're here
changing game settings you know we're
just doing it up this is the butter
knife Ron buttered it's good to know
that there are some avid Mon honey here
though
come back here shrim setup is one or two
pcs we have 2 pcs stream pcs ought to
tell you the wrong direction not that it
matters there's two stream pcs one on
the left one on the right
we're sorry there's one stream PC and
the PC we're gaming on that would be the
most optimal if you if you can afford it
obviously that's not cheap to have two
pcs I personally at home used to just
stream off the same PC I was playing but
you know that does obviously take up
some of your cpu to do that but you know
no way for the weapon skin mods it's
gonna be great just imagining the type
of stuff that you can get how's your
butter knife doing you know it's slowly
but surely there is like poop it out
so I have exactly the same rig is that
cool yeah I know I can't confirm if it's
a 7700 K we'll do that after can't wait
to have a keyblade get that Kingdom
Hearts that we do I swear I swear we
need to go back into the 2018 logs I
swear to you I told somebody that
Kingdom Hearts would get delayed one
more time and it did right it's 2019
right Mike's crazy for that hi I'm not
I'm not up in the kingdom heart so I'm
just I'm along for the ride
I'll pick up Kingdom Hearts 3 to play it
because I like like Toy Story and stuff
January 25 2009 I swear I wish there's
an avid fan out there like a goob Schuur
I wish I could go back in time and get
me like saying that I'm like dude
there's no way it's gonna delay one more
time trusting one of those you know how
like we always try to do the 2018
predictions you have things I feel like
that's something I wrote but I could be
wrong who knows most extended monster
bites they're not not for everyone yeah
I agreed cyber shocker that is the
interesting thing was there was a lot of
folks that picked up Monster Hunter
world because it was you know finally on
accounts like a bigger platform right
other than handhelds and I would say
there's a decent amount of people that
actually didn't end up enjoying it but
at the same time there were you know a
decent amount people that did so it's
definitely not for everyone
it's Capcom's memorable consoling like
game yeah that's that's pretty big but
uh because I know some people that
didn't get into it and like I was like
nah you just got to give it a chance man
you got it like once you get good and
it's like blood warning get the patterns
down and everything it feels really good
because some of these longer drawn-out
monster fights that we're talking about
like dude if you get optimal you can
really get to bar him like you know sub
sub 5 you know sub 5 to 10-minute kills
or even shorter if you're like really
good yeah you know you get some barrels
getting going on blows the barrels no I
can't capitalize on damage because I
we're going to my lowest
like thank you I can tell it's really
hard to see that screens color on the
carpet but hey you didn't want to
safe I respect it I respect the play I
really do oh he's not even limping he's
just running around to run around got a
butter knife man what do you what are we
gonna do here
mornings gonna make this game Gator
great I am oh geez like him another day
it's okay it's we need to exploit pad
Nicholas yeah right now could be worse
could have said something worse I feel
like it's true
that's it I put 130 hours on ps4 alone I
don't even want to know what mine's
actually you know it's not as high as
yours I think mine's so no you know what
it could be over a hundred easily
actually I have to take a look I I'm
willing to bet you're over yeah I've
gotta be around that I feel like I I
stopped when what you would call a came
cool uh cooler at their cooler what's
the big old guy that you don't really
fight hold her hold her off
I did I didn't get into that I stopped
after gold golden devil do I know I just
I didn't have that urge to start trying
other weapons I guess that's the other
part of the longevity of the game is um
learning the like you know picking up
another weapon mastering that farming
those mats for that etc I was just a
swag axe boy living a swag axe life oh
my goodness Mills no Savard i7 1070
normal thirty two weeks ago I believe
well don't we check all those specs
after because man I feel bad if I was
lying this whole time so you'll know
well like for 10 80s and year or like I
don't dude after the first time I tried
it SLI I've never believed in SL Iying I
never was a big fan of and like the cost
do GP all GPUs cost a lot because of
crypto mining would could you imagine
SLI in like to 1080p eyes man what would
you need that for mining bitcoins you
can buy more graphics cards cards I
guess exactly not an elf graphic card
look you don't you don't need that I
think Cole Vey is queen Jack Ross
I know about that they're running this
on a 1070 yes sir you once we did some
of those optimizations this frame rate
has been crispy you just got it just got
turned down that one set that volumetric
and then what's that right visa gala
seventy right filter vsync I think just
let's see I don't think you drop below
80 frames it's all my yeah I think so
let's go even in all these different
zones clothing damage model in who knows
should talk to this locality for K need
SLI if you want high FPS yeah but I mean
there's people out there and I'm not
judging them against that I'm just
saying like that's like a very I feel
like that's a niche demographic that one
that or or it can afford that I'm so
like oh yeah I'm 4k you don't need that
I think 1440p is kind of worried that to
be honest I still take like a solid
stable framerate
yeah for me over res for sure for sure
for sure but that's just me I guess no
Joseph says the most noticeable thing
about the FPS on this stream is how when
the particle effects go off it doesn't
drop to like 15 FPS module straight like
here watch my elemental discharge you're
ready for it and curity to drop 20
frames but ya know I'm really into how
good and this runs yeah um I'm gonna
definitely play some some more oh you
know what I should do I should try
installing it I'll do my home internet
so slow the Downloads got probably take
forever but I should try playing on my
980 and an i-5 and see what that life's
like yikes
alright no I think you know what
surprisingly at least for destiny it was
shockingly good or all things considered
alright based off of what I just told
you I've uh I only have I think I only
have eight gigs of RAM at home I might
have sixteen them
I have overclocked my my my CPU but it's
not like an and i7 rate at all is it
running max settings more or less for
what we can max settings except for the
one filter yeah that is apparently a
hinderance so can I get a beta access
sorry Bo box we happen to just have
special closed beta access not sure if
there's gonna be any type of beta before
the game launches because it's only 15
days out as a lot of chatters legend 2
percent believe me when I say that if I
could give beta access to literally
every single person and should I do it
this guy's a generous man how many gigs
on the install for us so far for the
closed beta is I think about my note no
numbers I 16.9 yeah that's being very
specific but yeah Oh apparently IDN
raining at a 980 and it ran six at sixty
dang
alright did they have to lower anything
else I started they mess with the
settings much sure it's like turns out
all they had to do was turn off that
volume metric where we're getting we're
getting into the dirt right now well I
don't love destiny too as much as we get
like destiny but I like testing - is it
a solid game
I love destiny as a video game like in
how it plays I don't the gun mechanics
the sound the shooting all that stuff is
good I just wish the content was better
yeah but that's just the more watch this
the further off oddest 9
seems can I just sleep for the next few
weeks maybe if you going to like cryo
just get a cryo phone
Joseph I don't know if that's safe yet
in our day and age but you know they've
done it in the movies so why not hope of
hell says destiny - it's fun but
warframe though see I'm getting back
into work I wanted to do that but then
like I don't know and maybe I'm doing
this to myself but like I ever heard
warframe
can be a tricky game to get into because
it has a lot of systems and it's better
to have like somebody knowledgeable
about the game kind of like just like
guide you along help you through it said
like you know really you know not get
frustrated potentially but that could
just be me and what I heard so
here we go oh my goodness
nailed it I can't believe this here I'll
get him on the on the way down I won't
get him on the way down Hassan or Hassan
1070 just got here optimization decent
yes so far from what we can tell a death
Slayer Isla said it was on high 50 on
the highest I'm guessing that was the in
regards to the idea industry cuz on high
settings for IGN and ran around 60 on a
92 that's pretty good yeah I will try to
report back tomorrow once I actually try
that home assuming I could download my
my internet speed is not the greatest so
I'm afraid for the download I think
you're gonna be good Oracle yeah we're
gonna be good
just keep playing the better game you
have in front of you hey we need eye
drops and I can't tell you this for sure
but I'm pretty sure I dropped around a
hundred hours in the monster on it so I
you know yeah Ted I remember when you
were kind of like how do I really want
to like what is this and then you you
got into it and you just kind of like
ran with it I was all in like I just
gave you like it kind of like oh oh yeah
this is kind of how it works and then
you just win and here we are a nick so
we are not streaming on the same PC that
we're running the game on its going to
another PC so that would obviously take
up some of your seat CPUs processing
power if you were to try to stream from
the same PC so beware obviously
do you need to be online all the time to
play this I don't think so you can be
offline worry on lines for the
multiplayer we're offline right now
actually because of disconnected us it
happens I got disconnected up my thing -
yeah I didn't actually played with
volumetric option on I believe they
turned down some other settings though
and had around 60 FPS at 1080p ah Thank
You Mac so we got that that single
setting solution boom what a triple ask
what's the setting for the anti-aliasing
on its turned on what are the highest is
it's like I'm gonna say a or yeah I
earned it all the way to the right until
the next option was off okay yo dagger
arm says IGN's 980 stream had dropped
below had drops below 60 even when they
drop settings to medium though they had
the volumetric rendering on so yeah
apparently as I think maybe Joseph if
said or someone else in chat said like
that that's setting alone might be 20
FPS yes what people were saying and
we're kind of seeing that now because
when we're fighting the pukka pukka we
were probably closer to 60 ish and now
we're like we've been out like dude
we're at 91 fighting an animation
they're like pretty good too we will
double check the rig's full specs after
this just so I can give you guys a
proper stop how does it feel on keyboard
malice I think it takes getting used to
I think if you've been playing on a
controller it's gonna feel real foreign
if you haven't played at all maybe you
just bite the bullet and learn on
keyboard mouse foot I think it's been
agreed that I think that controller just
feels better
yeah keyboard mouse is doable but I'd
say play with a girl or I laughed
because chilling accounts that this is
horrible i want the monster to quit you
know that's fair they might actually win
no gives the viewers there's always a
chance narrow the fight with your butter
knife I mean it might be the easier way
out well this game have ps4 controller
our Xbox controls so far from what we
can tell we plug in a ps4 controller
after the fact it still has the Xbox
control setting not sure if that's
something where if you exit it out and
came back in which we could try to test
will change
wouldn't be shocked if it just kept the
Xbox controllers settings though yeah
but I haven't tested it we know those
buttons exist because we played it on
PSP whoo
so the game stays out of solid 4k 60fps
that I'm not sure of because we're not
playing a 4k we're playing a 1080 I'd
have to test that outside at my desk
where I have a 4k monitor and I have a
better rig out there though
whoo
our Terra where it does bring up a good
point it's funny how people still ask
can I run it with a 1080p or 10 1080 on
their hands yeah I
it depends though they could have it's
sad Ram they could have it's just a
curiosity you know you it's kind of like
you want to be reassured like yes I know
this will run but hearing it from
someone with a similar situation is in a
1070 almost double the strength of a 98
I don't think it's doable and someone in
chat can probably that that seems
there's a lot of knowledgeable folks in
chat thank you that could could explain
it better I don't think a 98 1070 has
double the strength of a 980 though
because I think if I don't if I recall
correctly a 980 is almost like a 1060
I think ish or somewhere in there or
maybe a 1050 so I don't know if it's
double
but someone in check and can help you
out there wise old dude so at that 120
when we're standing still 144 160 150
170 I mean we had 200 at some point -
gotta sharpen yeah we got a we got a
real cracker day one butter knife we're
butter knife running it right now we're
gonna we're gonna get an upgrade it'll
probably help out a bit Ralph we are not
using specific presets been actually
winning and pretty much turned
everything that he could manually to
high when you set it to the the default
high it doesn't actually set everything
in the options to high you have to do it
manually there are two or three of them
that go to like a second highest or
something yeah so says 980 is similar to
a 1060 3g x xh miss as a 980 TI is at
1070 he thinks or she thinks um sweater
he's smooth at 1080p 1080p with the 1070
yeah definitely it's you know I don't
want to spoil anything actually yeah I
was gonna say ice pop this guy was gonna
do more yeah to be honest with you I
mean he shows up yeah so he's owed
degrom kind of saying what I said
earlier 980 is close to 1060 so yeah
1070 is 20% more strength in a 980ti
so maybe 50% of a 980 okay so if it is
50% of a 1980s in that double then
roughly I don't know something like that
Oh 1070 you should be between a 980 and
1980 TI Cesare zero so we're close it's
somewhere in there maybe not double the
string I love Mills part hey man I look
at a wall the PS board I get as high as
40 FPS boom there it is that's the
technology you can't skip this all you
like I don't think so yoke but we're
gonna see that we can see the frame rate
for all these cutscenes that's 90 fps
drinking you ever drink at 90 FPS it's
wild smash your mommy says graphics kind
of look bad when you're close to
something that looks alright to me it
looks better than on the the council's I
can at least say that yeah I can't get
over it either Joseph just turning off
that one setting it makes it look better
and better it's crazy just patch it out
take it out yeah that's fine now that
you know what to do praise we're in the
character customizations that's actually
fair it's already in the game yeah well
they gave us like half the other NPCs
hairstyles at least but well double
check the specs of our PC here in a
second right after this so we can
actually go into like PC settings and I
can tell you what it properly is the
option to change the voice of the
traditional gibberish yes it's still
there get that that Monster Hunter
language I just said it to Japanese
because but yeah what system did we turn
off uh it's the volumetric option which
is not actually volumetric it's like
volume something rendering I forgot it
already there's only one that's in the
and the graphic said and called volume
something rending and rendering and we
turned that off that was that that was a
big one is there a blank slider and this
customizer no cyber shocker sorry at
least no no no no they're sort of like
have no because I wasn't I was thinking
about it cuz I just made a female
because I made a male on ps4 and then I
was thinking about it was like wait were
there sliders and then like I was like
wait no there isn't so what setting
affects the can you show it to him yeah
it's
[Music]
it's not there it's not here it's here
it's this one the volume rendering
quality there you go turn that off for
sure turn that off it'll be good you'll
love it
hi yes sir I don't have a controller for
PC so we'll keep water mouthfeel smooth
for this game I mean I think so unless
you happen to play your muscle hunter
previously on controller then it might
be weird to transition but if you've
never played I'm sure you could get used
to the muscle memory of mouse and
keyboard it's fine it's just as somebody
and I'll just speak for myself but as
somebody who's played on a controller
I'm just used to that yeah though the
the buttons were kind of kind of weird
melee stuff is much more manageable than
the ranged at least turn out like I
think I could probably play most melee
things with mouse and keyboard reliably
right now we're just with a little bit
of time I've had yeah but yeah without
key bindings or more time range stuff
would be kind of by the way capturing in
most cases is faster than killing if you
didn't know that or it's very true I'm
having to capture equipment yeah what do
you need to play in closed beta
unfortunately final map ler we just have
a like industry type code or connection
with Capcom that they allowed us to
basically play the game
what is volumetric setting dude I was
like it was weird because it was like
almost like detrimental it was like
giving you this like blue blur in the
background that like I don't know it's
so much clearer now that we've turned it
off so I'm not exactly sure what it does
Ralph so I'm sorry that I can't yeah
exactly explain what it is but I'm sure
if you google volume render quality to
be a thing might tell you what it is am
all right do you want to yeah why don't
we would check a thing yeah do you want
to like close out and then check the
actual PC specs and then maybe what can
we can put it back up to see if it
changed and do the double save I gotta I
always did that too I always did the
save watched it save do the quick game
and let it exactly you got to do it both
ways cuz that's that's how you're sure
and you know what was really annoying
about PlayStation I always had the
clouds make sure iCloud saved yeah all
right here we go so we're gonna go check
PC settings which I think
Ben knows what to do hopefully what is
yeah well go camera while you why is it
it's totally to play metal gear it knows
it's we gotta go no I'm gonna bring it
back in a second actually we need not
gonna show us searching for it that's
all
to Thurstone in here alright so I was
right I 7 with a 7700 K 32 gigs of RAM
and do you have if you go into vice
manager and we can show that we have a
1017 but I'm almost positive it's a 1070
I'm gonna feel real bad if it was a 1080
because it could there you go you got it
I built that machine thank goodness I
remember still remember at all um so
yeah I 7700 K 32 gigs of RAM you
probably mean either you give the RAM 16
gigs probably plenty and a 1070 that's
what we were playing on today I would
try to update our video description with
that because that's what everyone wants
to know you I thought you were gonna
potato mode for the laws no we're gonna
do a proper there'll be a proper potato
mode for sure when I'm Joey I'm down to
after we get the start up and we see the
buttons I'm also I'm gonna show the
settings - let's do it let's go into
that let's just do a fun thing let's do
a fun thing let's see how high we can
get these these frames how we can do
this nice that's a pretty much pretty
nice machine that the game runs well
yeah like I said I think our rig in here
not even counting our outside rig is
definitely above average it's safe to -
compared to what most people have out
there but I mean I think that if i GN as
mentioned by some of the other people in
the stream earlier running out on a 980
at medium and they were getting 1080
with 60 at like consistent 60fps I think
that's pretty good I think that's pretty
good I'll I'm gonna try watch better the
menu looks with that thing turned off
yeah
oh I'll have to double check and try to
keep you guys updated maybe the next
time we do a stream because I'm gonna I
have a 980 at home with an i5
overclocked it's a pretty old rig I
think it might only have eight gigs and
RAM so that'll be a good test
I think to do low mix although baby see
you can you can take everything a little
bit like a step further because it 512
but let's take it technically you can't
you don't have the potato I don't have
to put the potato fire no one can drive
the potato fire except you Joey yeah
what is he doing he has the codes
memorized at this point it's crazy
alright so we're gonna do two things
we're gonna check on buttons for ps4 to
see if I'm gonna turn this off I don't
know what the hell Z prepass is but
we're not gonna admit world I'm curious
max LOD level let's negative 1 z
prepress is that what Z pre pass pass I
think this is I think this is as low as
you can turn our it's casual effects
says that it's considered irrelevant but
that was in 2013 let's make sure it took
yeah it's all there confirmed when we go
to see the potato test as well we
haven't published the video yet because
this is still before the game cuz its
beta but we will do it probably around
the time the game launches damn 3 hour
almost 4 hours play time that's we're
already on the road from Oster hunter oh
we're working on it Luke oh code right
now I want the beta Tuesday's MultiAir
oh sorry unfortunate and I wish that we
future needs you on the low ski or
killing it off not even that bad this
isn't this is not bad it's not great
it's like if the ps4 ran more than 26
frames a second we're at 140 frames
though yeah yeah we're killing it I
would play it like this yeah I I do not
mind I'd take this over 4k and
everything turned up if I had to like
she was one of the other and the other
one had like oh you got to play at 20
FPS looks like ps4 see there right on my
same wavelength
see ya great and faith says no that's
not bad that's playable the loading is
so-so oh you know what we didn't check
the check if D Drive was ace SSD or not
which we can checks though yeah do we
want to do priority queue he says it's
not a beta Capcom made certain people
get it early to review I guess that's
fair the they told us tonight
technically it's a closed beta
yeah that was the messaging to us so
that's what we're doing
we got good save there thank you yeah
otherwise I would have been the guy that
titled this dream and all things
would've been wrong face is still fine
face alright the the scar looks kind of
vegetation looks a bit gross but yeah
it's fine yeah we're still sure yeah
those frames though right am i right so
there's so many frames it's not 60fps
kept no you can't cast so you can you
can cap it at 30 60 or you can have it
completely open yeah so we have it right
now set to no limit limit Soulja let's
take it down to 30
oh hey yeah this doesn't feel like 30 if
you want to play a 30 everyone is this
ultra settings definitely not definitely
opposite this is low settings this is
about as low as it gets this this is not
30fps you know it says 30 up there I'm
telling you right now
yike or Rooney's bad kind of actually
yeah can you at least put it back to 60
yeah won't you try 60 there's a hot
Aaron
oh it's it just like exists when you
move that's cuz you turned on or off you
sync is off ok but yeah that's that's a
screen tear it's still playable y'all
it's beer its playable I'm so hyped
right now this game can't come out
sooner yeah a lot of people alright
let's go back to No Limit so let's get
back that I guess the last thing we need
to check once you have time is that SSD
will double-check I could this could be
the one I'm wrong on out of everything
Heiko Rooney's haha yeah new new term
coined here that's some s yeah are you
gonna do exit out and try to find out
what our hard drive is yeah you might
have to device manager it again that's
fine that's that's it can't just be a
SATA hard drive but you know we'll find
out we will do some investigating all
right on my screen my preview screen
yeah right it's Drive
yeah it's a I think that's yeah I'm
pretty sure that's can't read these
numbers
WD I'm pretty sure that's just a that's
just a WC mmm I don't know what that is
I can't read the rest of it I mean that
that's an SSD SSD for sure it's it yeah
it's it's it's just a SATA Drive there
you go boom so if you had an SSD could
you imagine the possibilities the
loading screens would not exist the
possibilities anyways I just want to say
thank you everyone for tuning in we
appreciate it we did play on highest
highest that we thought we could then we
adjusted and turned off that filter that
gave us all the frames volume rendering
quality turn that on turn that off so
make a PSA article for that one I don't
write Cortland Robinson are you all
doing more anymore Hans not today
unfortunately technically we have about
like our 15 hour 30 of more wiggle room
before the game actually launches so you
never know we might do another another
stream it will co-op it or something or
have two people hunting since I have it
you have has it person but we are gonna
plan on bringing back our community play
date stuff so John Luke and I will be
doing that and master hunter is
definitely a go-to for us so if you want
to play with us when the game comes out
to roughly you say says you have a 960
Evo but you don't put your games on that
sad frog face picnic it's a paper your
hands anyways uh you know why we have
too many games that it starts to kind of
overload that Drive
so technically some of the stuffs going
to the storage drive but you know I mean
I guess in certain cases which we could
have bumped down the the resolution we
could have changed a whole bunch of
stuff got a 500 yes don't worry keep an
eye out for potato mode from lost your
hunter woo woo it's gonna be a doozy
we're get a thousand yes 2000 FPS turn
off volume right rendering quality yeah
maybe we'll just do it we'll just do a
PSA there's something tell Michael I'm
gonna get on that anyways thanks man for
playing and enduring the keyboard mouse
for at least half the stream it was a
good time oh it was still in still the
Xbox okay I paid attention I looked I
got you that's why you're here yeah yeah
alright
anyways yeah definitely do a PSA in the
volume it yeah I think that's fair um
yeah but that's it thank you guys for
tuning in
come back tomorrow if you want to you
hang out at 11 a.m. for a GameSpot daily
for the hottest news gaming news of the
day in 15 minutes or less and then
GameSpot live we'll be back tomorrow
everyone's favorite game for tonight
just back again be sure most people them
but 49 challenges we'll be doing that
tomorrow I'll be doing that with Sam I
think and Friday you and John Luke will
have your fun community stream of course
we'll stop GameSpot daily if you haven't
hit that sub button or follow button do
so so you guys get notified and informed
as to when we go live and/or when we
make cool content or PSAs like turning
off volume rendering quality turn it off
Thank You Joseph Knibb I think he was
the one that brought it to our attention
yes appreciate it until next time peace
out have a good Wednesday
see you bye see ya that kind of didn't
play the way I wanted it to but look
outro